hey hey
when I look back with this award season
what will I remember looks
I think one of the things that stands
out is we did a screening for the DGA
there was an asian forever thing and
when we're done that screaming he
started walking towards and I tell the
end reply and he said what I'm doing
said he was going to sound weird but i
am mary jones and I'm Tamara Jones to my
brother
and we both breaks se trata
relations des priceless because of that
moment I needed ever up his life open
forever change for watching that piece
of all about McCain speechless under
No
one back
why is that because I think the
University said you have a lot of nerve
any question the film is so dramatic
heavy are you the type to have to say
character or when you break and joke
around liven things up the moment mr.
day said cut we had a baton like I said
previously honestly said don't judge it
just be it and we do a floor so the
moment he said cut wherever Jones was
left on the floor thank you babe
poor my routing form Sunday everybody
it's a beautiful day baby to get to that
place so everybody that walks that up is
Sunday
reporter I'm ready for you told
sir values memo how did your sisters
wardrobe help you embody your character
well when you look at the wardrobe that
Lisa Cortes found in her college from
Erik Jones and 86 and when you watch the
the opposition when you land Oh God
after she choose that well she was
mentally ill and like I said Lisa go
handle thought it's in a closet but you
know I think that it really allowed
Marie Joseph something life even more
because you put those things on and
tattooed and width and the big heavy
clothes that's how you begin to feel
thank you I don't want to say first of
all congratulations I thought you were
amazing in the movie a lot of the
discussion around the movie was how Gaby
breaks the traditional young Hollywood
Bowl one of the reasons that I respect
you so much the figures because you're
so outspoken so i was wondering if i
could get your opinion on the recent
Vanity Fair cover story of how popular
Hollywood usually intends to reward
those who are young usually white and of
a certain weight and Oscar sizes those
who don't fit that
you want to know how I feel about the
pebble yeah what was to come for example
um it was the Vanity Fair young
Hollywood cover and it was all young
white actresses very skinny and we're
taking action saying yeah what it was
what's young and hot in Hollywood was it
like this is the new Hollywood yeah well
they may actually be questioned how
would you feel I I was looking for daddy
so what's the world you know thank you
you know when mr. day is first talking
about the character first told me about
the book and then his script and coming
from a background of being molested I
knew who mary jones was when you said
action i was excited to bring that
character to life with no lollipop and
bubblegum putting a little we gotta ease
it up a little bit because then the
truth when you've been told so he said
action when you watch that film we want
to do too
be that precious expressions and
marriage Ole Miss Mary Joan was not it
was Monique acting we want you to
believe those characters know who they
are because you walked away different
because you know those characters you
make a marriage offer you maybe
pressures at one time or another in your
life so in rural people walked away we
wanted you to feel like this is real
this is not Hollywood and in staff is
amazing ending when you know life just
don't work out that way even though the
ending was beautiful but she still
walked away with HIV she still walk away
from mentally in the capture she still
walking with a brother and a son like
the situation was still what it was but
she walked away from it with my head
held high but we know that in real life
so I'm very proud to be a part of
something that for as long as within
this life and it goes down in history
you will see something or next time that
has changed people's outlook they woke
up different when I finished a film
and it allowed me not to judge nothing
and nobody because in your darkest
moment when things just seem like they
can't get any better for you don't you
want somebody love you through it that's
what the syllabus for us to simply love
through it and stuff judge it son look
at that people just automatically
putting over too big they are and not
even asking the questions let's stop
doing that if we do you'll be surprised
with the outcome might be you'll be
surprised what your tomorrow morning
might be when you go back to being
denied and you pray please don't let me
be judgmental because if they only knew
what was going on in my closet mm-hmm
who would then they say about me so
treat people not you truly want to be
treated and watch what the universe will
do god bless